All right, let's get into Corona virus.
For the last few days, I've been more and
more concerned that Donald Trump is utterly
and completely unprepared to deal with the
Corona virus and it potentially becoming a
pandemic that will affect the United States
as well as the entire world. As of this morning,
there are more than 81,000 coronavirus cases
that we know of and more than 2,700 deaths.
Yesterday we spoke with a, I spoke with a
doctor specializing in infectology about their
trajectory prevention, how to manage something
like Corona virus. The cases are still mostly
centered in China. More recently, there's
been a pretty significant uptick in South
Korea. Then you've got Italy, Japan, and Iran
as of this morning with a lot of, with more
cases than most countries in the U S 60 cases
as of this morning. But there is every expectation
that this is going to get worse before it
gets better. And a presidential administration
has a large role to play in managing the situation.
We will talk about preparedness. We will talk
about who's in charge. We will talk about
fairings. That will certainly be a disadvantage
to dealing with coronavirus and even Republican
Senator. Mitt Romney is willing to say that
the Trump administration is completely unprepared
for a widely spread Corona virus in the United
States. There's a report that Mitt Romney
actually confronted Trump administration officials
at a private briefing in D C yesterday. As
Trump has continued to publicly downplay concerns,
say it's under control, it's going to go away.
When it gets warm, we're going to be fine.
The stock market's going to be fine. The reality
is that this is now a red alert. Even Republican
Senator John Kennedy during a hearing made
it very clear that he doesn't believe the
Trump administration is even remotely competent
and prepared on this issue and when everything
is sport to the president. Being unprepared
for something like this will lead to deaths.
I tweeted earlier today, people who say, I'm
not into politics. If there's any silver lining
about this whole coronavirus fiasco, it is
that I hope people who say I'm not into politics
realize that politics can very quickly become
life and death. Look at Donald Trump's recent
tweets tweeting it's self congratulatory,
pablum quoting Gordon Chang on the Laura Ingraham
show saying quote us acted on the Corona virus
very, very quickly tweeting how great he is
doing at handling it. Quote, CDC and my administration
are doing a great job of handling coronavirus,
including the very early closing of our borders
to certain areas of the world. It was opposed
by the Dems too soon, but turned out to be
the correct decision. Trump is focused on
attacking Democrats, making fun of many Mike
Bloomberg and claiming victory for things
he hasn't done, like building the wall instead
of actually dealing with a deadly contagious
disease.
It's just not a priority for Trump. It's underfunded.
Trump has no idea what's going on, so we have
a twofold problem here. They are woefully
unprepared, but they are also downplaying
it for political reasons. It'll disappear
when it gets warm. They've been saying more
and more, almost like it works that, uh, you
know, th th th like the disease is going to
melt or something like that. And dr [inaudible]
told us yesterday that this is not something
we can assume that this will go away when
it gets warm in the Northern hemisphere. We've
already heard from Harvard, epidemiologist,
Mark lipstick, who predicts that Corona virus
will ultimately not be containable. And within
the year it's conceivable that up to 70% of
the world population could be infected. Now,
the death rate may never rise beyond 2% but
when that many people are infected, you are
going to have many people die if it gets to
that level.
I'm not being alarmist, I'm showing that even
experts say this could happen if it's not
taken more seriously by all government. And
that includes Trump. Now additionally, it's
important to look at death rates by age. When
you do that, you notice that below age 40,
the Corona virus death rate is just 0.2% even
between 40 and 49. It's just 0.4% above 50
years of age. The death rate starts to climb.
And of course if you're 70 or older or even
more acutely, 80 or older, you are the most
at risk. That's the case with regular flu.
That's the case with pneumonia. That's the
case with a number of different conditions.
And I've actually seen what seemed to me like
horribly a macabre arguments that we don't
have to worry about the economy because the
people of working age are not dying at a high
rate from Corona virus.
So we don't really have to worry. Can you
imagine? And Donald Trump's ignorance and
the denials are, are, it's not just a political
game at this point. We're talking about people's
lives and after this short break, I want to
get right back into Corona virus and talk
about who Donald Trump is putting in charge.
Hint, it's Mike Pence who barely believes
in science. And then I also, uh, after that
want to continue talking about this because
there is a talking point spreading that Donald
Trump fired his pandemic response team and
there are a bunch of people saying that couldn't
possibly be true, could it? It is very true.
It is not only true that Trump fired his pandemic
response team, he also reduced funding to
the CDC and it is all just
bad and we'll get to more of it after the
break. Make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram at David Pakman show
and while you're at it, follow